all right this is a Fox News Alert
breaking tonight if you are just joining
us Federal prosecutors have just filed
nine new charges against Hunter Biden
all related to a tax evasion scheme but
the the pressing question of the night
is well what does this mean for the
president what did he know when did he
know it and by the way when are far
Farah charges ever going to be filed
will they be filed here with analysis
law professor and Fox News contributor
Jonathan Turley Jonathan you have been
one of the few honest Democrats that
have been pointing out this is a very
real scandal with real implications for
Joe Biden and even though people in the
media wanted to go away people in the
Democratic party wanted to go away
you've been warning them it's not going
away and I think all roads now lead back
to 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue and Joe
Biden has a lot to answer for starting
with why he lied repeatedly to the
country including
yesterday well I think that's true you
know the fact is that this is a circle
that's getting tighter around the
president I mean it's clear that the
president has lied he obviously lied
during the ca first campaign when he
said he had no knowledge of these
dealings Hunter himself contradicted
that Hunter's Associates said that it
was utter nonsense in recent statements
after his testimony uh he also said that
his son didn't make any money in China
that obvious ly is not true but there's
a more serious problem here and that is
what the president knew of was not
business dealings it was corruption
that's what influence pedaling is the
United States has pushed International
agreements uh to stop influence pedaling
in other countries the United States
believes it is a leading source of
destructive corruption and if the
president knew that his family was
engaging in that type of corruption of
course it's serious so we're looking at
two V uh events next week one is when
Hunter Biden is supposed to appear um
that may now be effectively scuttled
Hunter may be able to use this to plead
the fifth uh to refuse to answer
questions but the second event is the
expected vote on the impeachment inquiry
and this indictment might make it easier
for Hunter not to speak but it may make
it more difficult for President Biden to
avoid that inquiry you know the the fact
is that this indictment shatters years
of denials by the bidens and frankly by
an enabling media uh it shows these
massive amounts of money uh going to
Hunter Biden from Romania Ukraine China
all these sources and it also shows a
knowing and continual effort to evade
taxes to commit criminal acts now if
this circle is getting closer to the
president then he has to answer some
question so it leads us to this very
simple question for the next week is any
Democrat going to stand up and have this
moment of courage and to say you know
what enough you know we we can't say
we're against corruption and influence
pedaling and then say we don't even want
to do an inquiry as to whether there's
so when you look at the lies we start
there then you look at the sheer number
of of suspicious activity reports then
you look at the identified shell
corporations with no real business
purpose except to move money around then
the sheer amount of money tens of
millions of dollars uh with no evidence
of any services rendered of any kind um
and then the big question is like for
example in the case of barisma did Joe
Biden as vice president take official
action that financially benefited his
family because 18 USC I believe it is
201 that's the bribery statute Jonathan
Turley bribery High crimes misdemeanors
I think you know where those words come
from that's right and when I testified
in the first Biden impeachment one of
the things I emphasized was this
speculation of whether the president
benefited from this money is absolutely
abs ABD in in federal cases it's well
established that if people give money to
your family it can be bribery and many
of the Democrats are just simply
ignoring that fact uh but there's also a
collision problem here with Hunter Biden
in the H in the gun charges his Council
has said you know what he had he came
out of an addiction around the time that
he signed that form and so he was
signing a truth because he had Clarity
well the problem is a lot of these
crimes occurred during that period so
did he have Clarity with the tax
evasions that were being committed
during the same period amazing a lot of
questions to be answered uh Karine Jean
Pier's job just got a lot harder tonight
we'll see what she tries to say tomorrow
to spin out of this I don't think we'll
be hearing from Joe much in the near
future Jonathan Turley thank you sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else